now the attacks on clarence thomas are
really ramping up so of course
which wizard made all the rounds on the
sunday shows of course of course it was
aoc and yeah she wants him impeached
that they can now lie
to duly elected members of the united
states senate in order to secure supreme
court uh nomin confirmations and and and
seats on the supreme court this is what
we're seeing lying at a confirmation
hearing is an impeachable offense
i believe so okay i believe so i believe
lying under oath is an impeachable
offense
i believe
that violating federal law in not
disclosing income from political
organizations as clarence thomas
did years ago is also potentially an
impeachable offense okay let's be clear
about something if lying under oath is
an impeachable offense then aoc should
be impeached right now and so should
laurie lightfoot and probably joe biden
and pretty much every democrat who is
demanding that we pack the court and
burn down all of our institutions their
oath of office is to defend the
constitution of the united states of
america that is in the very oath of
office it's right there up top right
what are you doing here as a
congresswoman as a senator you are
defending this document the founding
document that defends all of our rights
that's what you're defending do you
think that's what aoc is doing or would
she gladly
burn down the constitution of the united
states would she gladly pack a court so
that one branch of government
could have enough power to destroy
another branch of government she of
course would do that so you want to
start the impeachment game aoc uh we
should probably
start with you that's probably where we
should start uh we've got more from aoc
this decision and this policy will kill
people no matter what their what the
their spin and what their talking points
are and that's what the data shows and
that's what the statistics show we have
many ideas we have some ideas coming
from senator warren signed a letter
along with 25 other democratic senators
asking president biden to explore
opening healthcare clinics on federal
lands in red states
in order to help people access the
health care and abortion services that
they need
i know that she's not the brightest bulb
but uh if she thinks that this decision
is gonna get people killed does she know
what abortion is
does she know what abortion is say a
seventh a seven month abortion that
she'd be for does she consider that
killing someone she actually doesn't she
doesn't because the left has become
psychotically rabid and
and almost a death cult at this point
you know it really has because if you're
basically okay with seven month
abortions and eight-month abortions and
post-birth abortions uh then you're kind
of a death cult uh and this whole thing
again about packing the court packing
the court so that one branch right we
have this checks and balances thing
right you guys took civic some of you
know about this aoc does not um
doing that would be again a violation of
her oath of office but it's not just her
uh her whole squad ayanna presley you
know ayanna presley she's another wizard
uh she wants to pack the court
and finally uh given the extremism the
far-right extremism and the imbalance
and the compromise integrity of the
supreme court we need to expand the
courts
to restore balance and integrity
restore balance like she's obi-wan
kenobi i mean real piece of work these
people um
far right it's the far right that did
this the far right that has these
justices that are far smarter than that
woman or aoc uh who take their duty very
seriously uh sometimes they make
decisions that people on the right like
sometimes they make decisions that
people on the left like but if you don't
get what you want we must drastically
alter the entire system